[Yes.]
[You had 10 correct answers!]
Wir bewerten jeden tag etwas gut oder schlecht, schön oder hässlich, richtig oder falsch ist.
Aber wann ist etwas wirklich richtig?
Das Gesetz sagt uns was verboten ist aber
wir haben natürlich auch irgendwo unsere eigene Vorstellung von richtig und falsch.
Nur so können wir Entscheidungen im Alltag treffen, Impulse kontrollieren
und letztendlich überleben.
Könnte ich nicht nach eigenem Ermessen bewerten, ob es gut oder schlecht ist einen Fliegenpilz zu essen,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich triebgesteuert und unter Hunger hat diesen Fliegenpilz essen
und sterben.
Es ist also wichtig, dass wir selber ständig alles evaluieren und bewerten.
Aber warum kann uns genau das zum Verhängnis werden
und die wichtigste Frage von allen: Was hat das mit Giraffen zu tun?
Herzlich Willkommen zu einem neuen Video auf Doktor Whatson,
abonniert gerne den Kanal wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt. Wir posten jede Woche ein neues Video.
[...get the survey say "family".]
[No, no.]
[I don't believe it.]
[And here's the other thing...]
[We're in contact with aliens.]
['Cuz if you believe something it becomes your reallity.]
Wieso sehen wie die Welt so, wie wir sie sehen?
Was sorgt dafür, dass wir an manche Dinge glauben und an andere nicht?
Prägt sich unser Selbstbild nur durch Schlüsselerlebnisse, Bücher
und die Art und Weise wie wir erzogen wurden?
Sicherlich ist das ein sehr wichtiger Teil.
Es gibt aber auch einen Effekt, der euch jeden Tag beeinflusst.
Ein Effekt von dem ihr vielleicht noch nie gehört habt.
Der "Cofirmation Bias".
Einfach gesagt bedeutet dieser Effekt, dass wir unsere eigenen Hypothesen nicht testen,
sondern bestätigen wollen.
OK. Folgendes Beispiel:
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass Giraffen nicht wirklich existieren.
Klingt eigentlich gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich wenn man sich mal diese
unnatürlich langen Hälse anschaut.
Und auch wie die trinken. Habt ihr euch das mal angesehen?
Egal.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich mich, um meine Hypothese zu überprüfen, über Giraffen im Internet informieren.
Leider bedeutet aber auch selbstständiges Informieren fast immer auch
selektives Informieren.
Ab dem Moment in dem ich mich über Giraffen informieren möchte,
spielt mir mein Gehirn schon den ersten Streich.
Ich sehe eine Liste von Links also, was klicke ich zuerst an?
Nach einer Studie der Universität Amsterdam
werde ich unterbewusst einen Link anklicken,
der auf den ersten Blick mit meinem Weltbild übereinstimmt.
Wir Filtern also heraus, was uns nicht in den Kram passt.
Wegen des Confirmation Bias habe ich eine verzerrte Wahrnehmung meiner Umwelt.
Im Internet lese ich dann vielleicht etwas über den langen Hals von Giraffen,
der trotzdem nur aus sieben Wirbeln bestehen soll.
Ich habe vorher in meinem Leben noch nie eine echte Giraffe gesehen
also gleicht sich diese Information vielleicht mit meiner vorherigen Hypothese,
dass es Giraffen gar nicht wirklich gibt.
Als nächstes lese ich, dass Giraffen von der Regierung gebaute Roboter sind.
Ich sehe dieses Video von einer Fehlkonstruktion
und meine Hypothese wird noch weiter verstärkt.
Wir lieben es halt einfach richtig zu liegen.
Ab jetzt nehme ich selektiv im Alltag immer mehr Hinweise war:
Im Zoo ist das Giraffengehege auf einmal geschlossen,
"Wartungsarbeiten."
Im Internet finde ich gleichgesinnte Leute die auch dieser Verschwörung auf der Spur sind.
Die Nachricht über Giraffenbabys im Zoo?
Ablenkung.
Tierdokus?
Alles Propaganda.
Ergo, mehr oder weniger bewusst filtere ich Informationen die mein Weltbild nicht unterstützen heraus.
Und gegen den Confirmation Bias ist niemand wirklich immun.
Wir alle halten an unserer Meinung über bestimmte Themen fest,
selbst wenn wir mit Gegenbeweisen konfrontiert werden.
Aber warum ist das so?
Hierzu gibt es zwei verschiedene Erklärungen.
Manche Forscher sagen, dass kognitive Prozesse so strukturiert sind,
eine Hypothese zu bestätigen
Wir können also gar nicht anders, als automatisch nach Beweisen
anstatt nach Gegenargumenten für unsere Meinung zu suchen.
Das ist quasi eine Art Überlebensinstinkt.
Wir bleiben bei dem was wir kennen.
Alles andere könnte Gefahren mit sich bringen.
Erklärung Nummer 2 ist, dass das Widerlegen einer Hypothese
mit negativen Emotionen verbunden wird.
Schlechten Gefühlen versuchen wir, logischerweise, aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Im Falle von diesen sogenannten "Giraffen",
könnte das für dich bedeutet dir bewusst zu werden, dass du jahrelang falsch lagst.
Du hast offensichtliche Zeichen wie die schwarzen Zungen oder komischen Höcker auf dem Kopf
einfach akzeptiert.
Wake up Shepell!
Ich mein' es ist doch ganz klar ist, dass das irgendwelche Antennen sind,
mit der die Regierung diese Giraffen, "Giraffen", steuert, oder?
Ja ok, ist ja auch egal.
Was tun also um nicht diesen Confirmation Bias zum Opfer zu fallen?
Eigentlich sollte es ja reichen bescheid zu wissen und sich mit kritischen Informationen auseinanderzusetzen.
Oder?
Hier muss ich euch leider enttäuschen.
Wissen über den Confirmation Bias schützt uns leider nicht.
Praktisch ist es also nicht möglich Objektiv nach Informationen zu suchen.
Außer natürlich ihr abonniert Doktor Whatson auf Instagram,
denn wir haben vor kurzem mit Instagram News gestartet.
Wir posten jetzt jeden Morgen einen coolen Post zum Thema
Wissenschaft oder Technik also quasi Sachen aus dem Doktor Whatson Universum.
Ziemlich früh morgens also ihr könnt jeden Tag mit so 'nem coolen Post in den Tag starten, wenn ihr wollt.
Link ist unten in der Videobeschreibung, der allererste ganz oben
oder einfach "@doktorwhatson" auf Instagram.
Würd' mich freuen wenn ich euch da wiedersehe.
Ok, zurück zum Thema.
Besonders schwerwiegend wird der Confirmation Bias, wenn wir persönliches Interesse daran haben,
dass unsere Hypothese wahr ist.
Wenn ich mich frage ob ein Partner loyal ist, würde es mir weh tun herauszufinden, dass dem nicht so ist.
Deswegen frage ich einfach gar nicht und bin weniger kritisch.
Ich will es nicht wahrhaben.
Zusätzlich ist unser Weltbild ein großer Teil unserer Persönlichkeit.
Und wer will schon herausfinden, dass ein Teil seiner Persönlichkeit
"falsch ist."
Finden lässt sich der Confirmation Bias in fast allen Lebenslagen und Situationen.
Besonders problematisch wird es aber in der Wissenschaft.
Wissenschaftler wollen eben ihre eigenen Hypothesen bestätigt sehen.
Das hängt mit dem wissenschaftlichen System zusammen,
aber wahrscheinlich auch mit dem Confirmation Bias.
Selbst Arbeiten über den Confirmation Bias wird vorgeworfen von gerade diesen Effekt betroffen zu sein,
also Experimente so aufgebaut zu haben, dass sie den Confirmation Bias bestätigen.
Ihr seht also das ist ein ziemlicher Teufelskreis.
Deswegen bedient sich die Wissenschaft dem so genannten "Peer Reviewing"
Bevor ein Wissenschaftler etwas veröffentlichen kann
muss es, logischerweise, überprüft werden.
Am besten geeignet dafür sind natürlich andere Experten auf demselben Gebiet.
Peer Reviewing heißt also, dass jede Veröffentlichung von einer anderen Gruppe Wissenschaftlern zerpflückt wird,
um inhaltliche und methodische Fehler zu finden.
Erst nach dem erfolgreichen Peer Reviewing und der Überarbeitung
darf die Studie oder das Paper veröffentlicht werden.
Aber auch Peer Reviewing hat seine Limits.
Was wenn die korrekturlesenden Wissenschaftler ein persönliches Interesse an der Veröffentlichung haben?
Auch hier, ihr ahnt es, ist wieder der Confirmation Bias am Werk.
Trotzdem funktioniert Peer Reviewing aber gut genug um Veröffentlichungen zu testen.
Ganz ohne Confirmation Bias geht es halt einfach nicht.
Für euch im Alltag bedeutet das also, dass ihr versuchen solltet
euch mit so viel Kritik wie möglich auseinanderzusetzen.
Hierfür reicht schon der Austausch mit Bekannten,
denn in der Diskussion hat der Confirmation Bias einen großen Vorteil.
Er sorgt dafür dass ich die These meines Gesprächspartners
versuche zu widerlegen, während ich meine eigene Hypothese verteidige.
Da mein Gegenüber dasselbe tut sorgt der Confirmation Bias also dafür,
dass, zumindest theoretisch, aus einer Diskussion immer das beste Ergebnis hervorgeht.
Weil halt das beste Argument gewinnt.
Das klingt natürlich alles extrem optimistisch
und natürlich gibt es in der Praxis sehr viele unproduktive Diskussionen.
Ich meine, nur mal als Beispiel:
Versucht mal jemandem der noch nie eine Giraffe gesehen hat
zu erklären was eine Giraffe ist.
Niemand glaubte dir die Existenz eines langhalsigen Kamelpferdes mit Schlangen-Muster.
Wie auch dem Placebo-Effekt werdet ihr also den Confirmation Bias nie ganz los.
[Danke, aus!]
[Schlussklappe, Szene für die dritte.]
Ich mein, glaubt ihr an Giraffen?
Das ist doch offensichtlich von der Regierung gesteuert
also allein die Antennen oder habt ihr mal gesehen wie die miteinander kämpfen?
Die hauen ihre Hälse gegeneinander.
Also, dass das wirklich zu glauben ist, danke,
also,
wake up Shepell! Da muss man doch mal was machen.
Das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen.